عوامل كثيره تشير الى تفوق وسيله الدفع
بالبطاقه البنكيه على الوسائل الاخرى
فاكثر من 25 مليار بطاقه بنكيه يمتلكها
الناس حتى نهايه العام الماضي 2022 وهناك
توقعات بوصول العدد الى اكثر من 28 مليار
بطاقه بنكيه عالميا هذه البطاقات اصبحت
اسلوب حياه بالنسبه لكثيرين لدرجه ان
ملايين الاشخاص يحملون في محفظتهم بطاقه
او اكثر احيانا لاجل تعاملاتهم البنكيه
وبحسب الخبراء فان الكثيرين يعتبرون هذه
البطاقه الممغنطه اكثر امانا من اساليب
الدفع الاخرى الهاتفيه او غيرها حتى يرى
الناس ان سرقه هواتفهم قد تمنح المحتلين
فرصه لسرقه حساباتهم المصرفيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات